dude i've been watching that softball
let's go
boy i've been watching softball
dude am i a lesbian oh my gosh i've been
watching that s
ball baby a lot of thicky thicks out
there with them sticky sticks you know
that
dang i mean you could see i wish you
kind of knew the menstrual cycle of the
team so you were like oh okay these
these girls
they got a little grudge they got that
grudge
it would be like a grudge flow factor
okay
you know they showed like the moon the
moon going whatever you know these girls
are half moon and over here
and these is wolverine and over
here
but my god you know i i i i just love
watching it
i love watching the softball man i like
seeing him thighs i like stalking the
girls on instagram
i like doing it all you know you're with
your girl she's like what are you doing
on your phone you're like
i don't know
jmu just hit a homer
you know you're just getting in there
man
i need a girl and dude one thing that's
interesting to the crowd at the softball
game
is you could hear all these chirpers a
lot of women out there
not a lot of uh
not a lot of fear not a lot of uh
you know a lot of real bird on bird
action
a lot of ladies that like to uh
you know what i'm saying is taco tuesday
four days a week you know what i'm
saying you know what i'm saying
you know what i'm saying ah
i'm downstairs you know what i'm saying
you know what i'm saying
[Applause]
so oh yeah it's just fun to guess like
who's really
you know out there wallet hop and you
see some of the ladies you know in the
stands and they just really
um those biscuit friskers you know what
i'm saying these ladies out there they
just checking wallet on a lot of these
girls and
but it's all beautiful man it's all love
you know and happy gay pride and it's uh
man i just damn love softball and the
girl montana fouts through a damn
unlimited strikeouts or whatever it's
called like
jeepers you know and it's just
funny you see they are everybody out
there
they doing it and you see in the
distance you know
big tiffany's in the distance and she's
stunting like my daddy
you know what i'm saying she got some
you know she's just out there manny
fresh and it's just
really god it's good man i mean what a
and it's just fun to watch you know it
just there's a lot of action in those
games there's a lot of like excitement
by the ladies
whereas the guys they're it's a little
more too cool for school a lot of time
with the guys
you know it's all tobacco and spitting
and you know
or gum or whatever but the ladies
they're they
they got the cheers and the chants and
the
they're doing it all and they're
touching tits i mean i saw two of them
jump up in the air and just damn touch
tits brother
you know whoo i don't
they'll jump start a civic baby with
them milk knuckles baby let's go
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one